thank you
[Music]
anyway and introducing our guest host
for the day Mr Jason Cheney
wow
that's host
I I feel so honored you're welcome all
right are you ready
are you ready are you I'm ready okay
okay Stockton PD whoa okay it's a police
officer in Stockton which is in the Bay
Area okay nice arrested suspected serial
killer after seven victims in a year I
heard about this they caught them huh
they did I mean he's the host asking
wait they caught him so a sex best
serial killer in custody in Northern
California
whoa whoa easy
hey whoa special guests you gotta relax
sir special guest I say one word a
little weird is that okay
just double I as a as a guest I just
want to know you didn't introduce the
guest yet well today our guest is
Anthony Lee yeah
yeah all right
[Applause]
he had a question saying her name the
right way earlier but he's got the last
name for sure Lionheart yeah it's a good
last name it's a great last name I think
you yeah it's a very Majestic last name
it is it's very juicy awesome uh
continue it is right I also own a Jiu
Jitsu Studio that's where I work at
Pasadena I hired Nick
she's also 30 Chinese I'm also 31.2
percent Chinese oh [ __ ] I'm don't wanna
get it right how could you you look very
um well preserved for a Chinese person
right that's the Chinese version of me
well preserved well preserved only the
31.2 percent though yeah right that's
not that much it's not that much so
today we have arrested sex suspect
serial killer after seven victims in a
year did you hear that I I heard that
last time I heard it was at five now
there's two more sucks about this serial
killer after seven victims in the years
and these murders were this year huh
a suspect that it's serial killer is in
custody in Northern California and
police say they caught the guy while he
was looking for the next victim whoa
damn they barely saved somebody then
what if he was just grocery shopping
does it say like the type of people he
was going after
um or like Colleen asked what if he was
just grocery shopping right thank you
Anthony you know women are never heard
yeah don't answer a question answer my
question first yeah
foreign
[Laughter]
ly was arrested Saturday morning around
me Wesley Brown you don't know how
that's pronounced Weasley
don't come over here without my guest
house and tell me how to read my article
man okay okay
so Weasley Brownlee all right how
Weasley was he don't disrespect his name
Ronald Weasley or respect the killer's
name he's 30 43 years old so four and
then three was it
Church Saturday night
we're police oh she Stanley McFadden
says he's Irish probably Nevada
this is the most credible news source
is TMZ it's TMZ trust me says he
appeared to be
scoping out a new person to kill
Stockton PD was surveilling him that's
not how you read punctuations but
continue don't point on my [ __ ] just let
him go let me go
oh [ __ ] I'm trying to give you more
information Bart is and uh
don't do whatever you were doing you
said more information I'm trying to give
the information your inferences too that
you can draw you're gonna stop
interrupting after he left his house
in a card around 2 A.M oh yeah really
late at night it's an early morning some
would say late at night early morning
Upon A search Anthony Lee they say
they say they found him armed with a gun
one gun
and a mask around his neck so the mask
is around his neck
okay and this is where you guys Rift
[Laughter]
so cute
formula down I've never heard someone
like open up the forum for riffing
all right because when you read things
and then you read a thing and then you
guys start riffing okay so this is I
don't I don't go this is what you guys
this has to be the new segment where
like next time you come on the show you
just guess host for the rest of the day
Anthony will pick out articles and then
you just guest house because this is
gold yeah can you do the weather now
about my work no it's just different
Different Strokes for different folks
different things now say the things go
ahead man
um you know I think it's it's it's
really unfortunate that there's a serial
killer killing people in Stockton but
I'm glad they brought him in custody
McFadden must be from Ireland
did you think he was Irish too when he
said that now now that I want to riffle
that I don't know if you know but it was
around his neck what kind of mask does
he say I already said this information
so you got to say I don't know if you
know that though but was this guy's a
method of murder just shooting people
yeah how would he kill them Jason Cheney
are you talking about Weasley yeah this
is a hard time to talk we can't interact
with you while we riff I I honestly I
got to be very focused
ahead that's right that's what you do
read ahead so let's do it let's let's
riff guys okay hold on what do you think
what's the deal what's around your neck
I'll give you one more information yeah
yeah yeah give me one more information
you give me one more okay yeah so um six
men have been slain dating back to April
2021 yes Lane so it's like you know a
guy killed slaves like an active voice
you know a guy Slade slate yeah
all of whom ambushed so they ambushed
shot and killed five took place in
Stockton area up through September and
the final one happened in Oakland so two
different places more than a year ago a
seventh victim so there were six before
and now there's another seven yeah
a woman though
all right thank god dude it's like I'm
there
almost confused until you said that yeah
he's like oh [ __ ] two before nine
yeah oh [ __ ] a woman was also shot in
Stockton last year so but survived she
survived
[Applause]
a very strong women are great that's
right a good handful of victims are said
to be homeless they're homeless people
oh I've been attacking homeless people
wow yeah that's [ __ ] up so ironically
uh this is one of those situations where
uh it wasn't outside the fact that they
were all like homeless there was no like
struggle there was no beating there was
no like other crazy type of like I
needed to get some sort of like weird
hate and [ __ ] these people it was
someone just shooting Ambush shoot kill
period oh my God just [ __ ]
Unapologetic clean and just try and
balance and then basically the cops were
already investigating this guy because
he was a suspect and so they were
tailing him and they were they were
literally just investigating and kind of
like stalking him and then he was going
out at night at like 2 A.M from his spot
and they were just following him and he
had a mask around his thing he had a gun
on him so they [ __ ] jumped in there
found out that again he hasn't been
officially convicted of these yeah but
he is the leading suspect for all these
like you know serial murders and stuff
like that damn it's 125 000 War to help
uh from the public yeah they were
offering a bounty for the suspect
uh of up to 125 000 that's crazy that
they're even tracking them down because
I feel like in LA
um because our homeless problem is so
crazy if if anything happens they're
just gonna be like well if you guys have
crimes within your community that's you
guys just solve it because they even
have like the king uh I forgot the name
but it's almost like the leader of that
Block they'll have and then they're like
that's their your guys oh the block
Captain yeah yeah yeah like like if
people try to fly a drone down Skid Row
like those fools will come out
confiscated and that's theirs now and
you need to deal with those guys even to
the point though of like multiple
murders though that I don't know I mean
I'm thinking like based off what I
understand if it's like 20 or 30 maybe
but I feel like people die like every
day because it's its own their own world
that they're running you think they'll
like uh cops maybe have like found a um
particular Mo to the killer it's like oh
here's another Point Blank murder for no
reason there's no motives no evidence
it's just like a shot to the back head
and then like a week later it's like oh
[ __ ] here's another in the same kind of
area same type of killing it's like
let's not connect the dots yet and then
the third or the fourth or the fifth
it's like wait a minute here's another
semi pointless no witness no you know
what I mean like that ends up becoming a
pattern yeah that like something has to
happen that like a block Captain to a
homeless Street like can't you know what
I mean like police have to do something
it's kind of like uh when they find out
you know when those prostitutes are
getting killed by like serial killers
why do they always catch him at the
seventh one you know it's like because
they let it go a little bit which I I
kind of almost get that they might have
to right you can catch them yeah just to
like even get a an understanding is it
three that determines that you're cereal
you know what I mean like what's the
number before it becomes like this is it
I don't know I feel like I feel like
it's three or something [ __ ] like that
but it seems like it is harder to find
uh I would think rather than like a
murderer who was targeting Suburban
people I think it's it's harder to catch
evidence on a homeless person in general
because there's such little data around
them already yeah and the first thing
detectives go for is like incentives
and then when it's like like let's say
you have Nick or whatever and let's say
he has sitting on a million dollars it's
easier to start finding suspects like oh
is it Nick's business partner or is it
next like weird cousin he hasn't talked
to or whatever but then when you have
like a person that may or may not have
any other ties yeah there's just you're
just literally like shooting in the dark
you don't know why needle in a haystack
yeah you're like what the I don't even
know why anybody would blast this guy
from the back then like you assume at
that point
I guess uh and maybe this is like a dub
and I'm just trying to like semi
understand like what the [ __ ] is it just
hate is it just maybe he's just like
really angry and really sad and he just
wanted to like um take his anger out on
some people
I guess it's just crazy yeah sometimes
there's no rational reason he's just
nuts and that's an easier Target you
could probably get away with a higher
count before you're caught I think
because like like it again like if
someone killed me eventually someone's
gonna be like I haven't seen him all day
no we wouldn't notice I would hope
but I I think we need to move there's no
Mochi Donuts today
what's missing
you don't get a lot of Wellness checks
for you know low-income situations as
much unless you have a big family it's
kind of sad but yeah plus I also think
there's something intriguing especially
to the American perspective of like
serial killers in general and what that
may or may not promote you know what I
mean to Netflix deals
dude people are so dumbers dumber's a
hit he's yeah he's he's a national icon
right now dumber's back big time the
business is booming for a [ __ ] Dahmer
but apparently uh we were at a wedding
last night and people were saying that
uh
they have to tell people not to dress up
as Jeffrey Dahmer for Halloween
dude like you know Molly and me and she
was like what should we be following me
and I was like haha let's be dumber and
then I said it and I was like
I'm perpetuating the exact thing I
questioned sometimes yeah yeah yeah you
know what I mean because it's so it's uh
you know like outside out of mind yeah
everything on Netflix everything around
because Dahmer is popularized even as a
fictional show right now now that like
the conversations of Dom or like news
articles are like the person who killed
them is suddenly coming out with
interviews and suddenly it's like this
[ __ ] giant a serial killer story that
came decades ago is a trending topic
here in today can I say something that
is um I feel like Jeffrey Dahmer he also
just wants to be loved hmm
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]